[Music]
the conference on the future of europe
has landed in warsaw
the polish capital hosted the third and
final meeting of the european citizens
panel on climate the environment and
health over the weekend some 200
citizens participating in person and
online turned their panel's ideas into
concrete recommendations ideas ranging
from promoting healthy living and
improving access to healthcare to
reducing pollution and creating
sustainable consumption my group is
looking at
specific labeling regarding the
ecological footprint through that we
want to protect our environment we are
looking at the water consumption water
wasting in order to keep our groundwater
clean and our rivers clean
citizens also looked at the links
between public health and the
environment everything that's related to
the improvement of the environment is
also
linked to health discussion because
if we improve air quality and things
like that we also improve health
piace
[Music]
as well as ways to better protect
biodiversity participants
recommendations included concrete
proposals on improving rural public
transport eliminating unsustainable food
packaging
ending planned obsolescence and
incorporating the right to health care
into the treaty of the european union
august dorin and maria are among the
panel's 20 representatives who present
their 51 recommendations to the
conference plenary at the european
parliament in strasbourg
the recommendations will feed into a
final report which eu institutions have
to follow up on
[Music]